Katie ledecky kind enough to join us the
six-time Olympic medal winner five golds
and a silver and of course the Olympics
have been postponed until 2021 Katie
joins us now Katie thanks for joining us
how did you get the news about the
Olympics thanks for having me yeah I
woke up yesterday morning and checked my
phone and had an email about it and saw
some some tweets about it so woke up
yesterday morning and knew right away
and could kind of see it coming over the
last couple days so it wasn't too
surprised if the Olympics were going to
still be held what would you be doing
today training hard you know this is a
crucial period of of training typically
for us our Olympic childs were scheduled
for end of June with the games beginning
about a month after that so I would
actually be in Colorado Springs right
now training at altitude but I'm at my
apartment in the Bay Area so what are
you going to do inside most of the day
and do some dryland workout and just
watch some TV and read and do a few
other little things around the apartment
but I know that there's a bigger picture
with what's going on in the world but
you know on a scale of one to ten
disappointment level where are you you
know it's kind of hard to gauge that I
guess somewhere in the middle I mean
it's frustrating and disappointing but
we all understand the bigger picture
here and this is you know a pandemic
it's a global issue and almost every
country it's been impacted so my
immediate focus is the well-being of
myself my family everyone around me and
I'm just able to control that I can
control and when they tell us when we're
competing I'll hopefully be there you've
been great on social media been sending
out a lot of positive messages
what made you think to do this yeah I
think we all have to remain upbeat and I
think a lot of people my age especially
you know I'm 23 years old and I've seen
some college students not necessarily
following the guidelines the way they
should be and I think we need to
continue to get the message out that the
social distancing is really important
and we have to follow the guidelines
that the medical professionals are are
telling us to follow and we really need
to take those very seriously what's the
longest amount of time days or weeks
months that you've been out of the pool
typically at the end of each season I
think about a week and a half to two
weeks off I've never really thinkin much
more than that so we'll see how much
time I take off before we get back into
some really big training now it's okay
to take a little bit of a break it's we
know that this is kind of an extra year
that's being tacked on and it's going to
mean an extra year really hard training
so we can kind of use this time as a
mental reset and physical reset and know
that we'll be ready to go once we get
back into full training and preparing
for this interview I was watching video
view swimming and I like just trying to
understand like what makes you that
great where you can lap people that
you're swimming against wait what what
do you have that other swimmers don't
have Katie it's a lot of hard work and a
lot of hard work over a lot of years you
know I think a lot of people watch this
Slone at the Olympics and they think
it's once every four years sport but
it's every year for us there's something
and now I guess that's once every five
years but what do you do so well because
I you know I don't know the technique
and and just as a novice I'm looking you
do something special you know more than
anybody else a lot of people work hard
and train hard
yes it's technique it's the aerobic base
that I have that I still tough over a
lot of years I started swimming when I
was six years old and I think I was very
committed
from a very early age I always went to
practice would get there early and I
think it sounds silly but I think I kind
of built up some really good endurance
from a young age and I had great coaches
that taught me the right technique and
kept kept me very healthy I've never had
any any injuries that has just been able
to go to practice every day and I don't
know I guess I've had this determination
that maybe Summers was younger maybe
didn't have and I kind of used that to
establish a really great base from a
young age you competitive at everything
yeah I try to keep most of my
competitive edge for my swimming and try
to have fun when I do anything else
that's somewhat competitive but I try to
avoid competitive things outside of the
water planet if we're playing a board
game it's great playing basketball in
gym class yeah I love I love board games
yeah but if we played are you gonna be
competitive like you're gonna go for the
kill oh yeah yeah I've had a lot of
competitive travel games with my brother
where is your trophy room I don't you
know growing up I would keep all my
ribbons and medals and shoe boxes under
my bed so yes that's my trophy room you
must have a big bed like you've access
and where your medals they're at home
somewhere wait do you really not know
where they are no I do that cuz I'm on
the west coast take em around
do you ever take him out I think I'm out
for various events I think you know
something I really want to do is share
that gold medal with other people and
but it's really cool when you show a
little kid I bowled medal in their face
just lights up you can just see it
instantly so try to show it as many kids
as I can Michael Phelps says that he his
friends will borrow his
I never done that well he does have a
lot of medals though to let his friends
borrow yeah yeah do you think that that
number is attainable for you is that a
goal as competitive as you are you want
to go after Phelps his number no that's
not that's not a goal of mine I have my
own goals and I focus more on fun times
and each race I don't think about a huge
metal hole I you know you said I had six
medals I don't even really count it that
way I just kind of take it one race at a
time but how important is swimming to
you as far as how long do you do this
yeah it's a big part of my life
obviously I train in the water ten times
a week and do weight training on top of
that so it's a lot and I hope to be
competing for many years to come I think
at least through 2024 and
kind of take it year by year but I'm
excited about the future hold I use
floaties is that is like water wings is
that cool yeah man that's cool okay
thank you I appreciate dedicating yeah
are you very very sweet Hey it's great
to talk to you Congrats on your success
and you know we just have to wait an
extra year to see you in the pool but
thank you for all the things you're
doing on social media I think it's great
and belated happy birthday I think it
was what last week you turned 23 yeah a
little bit of a different birthday this
year but thank you that's Katie ledecky
the Olympic swimmer